hi there internet i'm john oliver host
of last week tonight a show that you
probably watch on youtube for free
although
maybe free isn't quite the right word
because even on youtube you do have to
look at
this meaning you are in a very real
sense paying a price
now we're still on hiatus at the moment
but we wanted to come back for a minute
to give you a quick update on something
we mentioned last season and it concerns
pringles you know the product that
looked at potato chips and inexplicably
thought what about that
but worse and delivered via tube you may
remember that towards the end of the
year
i played a clip of don lemon pestering a
man with questions about when
election results would come in that he
didn't have the answer to and i
responded
like this leave the man alone at that
point it would have been just as
productive to ask him
when will penguins learn how to fly or
when is michael keaton going to win an
oscar or what does the rest of the
pringle guy's body look like is he tall
or short does he have a lot of body hair
or is he completely smooth
when will he be able to tell me what his
nipples look like are you talking hours
or are you talking days now that was a
perfectly fine joke there because there
is
a lot that we don't know about the
pringles guy in fact the only thing
we do know is that his head looks like a
hard-boiled egg disguised as tom selleck
and i honestly didn't really think much
about that joke again
but it seems that a lot of you did
because after our show aired people went
out of their way to either draw or find
drawings of
what people feel the pringles guide does
look like from the neck down and at the
end of such a depressing
isolating year it was genuinely
uplifting to see
because you tweeted a variety of
illuminating drawings like this one
captioned mr pringle's nipple reveal
which seems to have combined the head of
mr pringles
with the body of baymax from big hero 6
with nipples in the belly button drawn
on
also the shorts of a sexual predator
then
there was this depiction of a portly mr
pringle sporting a bow tie and some
thriving armpit hair a look that just
screams
unemployed chippendale and there was an
artist who sent us
not one not two but three
excellent renderings of a body positive
mr pringle none of which
were produced for us by the way as his
capture notes i've dedicated the last
several years
to studying his anatomy and that is time
well spent
and i will say this he's single he
pringle he ready to mingle if that is
not
pringles new slogan they're exactly as
bad a company as i imagine they are
now a few of you knew exactly how good
the drawings that you found were like
this one captured
this picture of the pringles man is
canon which is simply
excellent others went in a different
direction like this
slender man mr pringles or this one
envisioning him as a hermit crab or this
spectacular piece portraying him as an
octopus
honestly the whole response has been
absolutely fantastic the only thing that
doesn't sit well with me is just how
silent pringles has been
on this matter because it's not like
they don't maintain an active twitter
presence they've tweeted before
if we named pringles the same way
football got its name pringles would be
known as mouth crisp
they've also tweeted mixed breeze
puppies i like the flavor stack
of puppies which actually feels
offensive i'm just not entirely sure why
but
still no answer to our very basic
question
and i know that they respond to people
online
because i've seen it once someone
tweeted at them
your sour cream and onion chips taste a
bit like throw up
but still they are my favorite is this a
problem to which pringles responded
immediately with
please send us a dm with your contact
information so we can get this handled
but the thing is
that person wasn't even complaining they
weren't looking for a refund
or free chips they wanted an answer and
the reason i know that
is because they shot back i was just
wondering if that is a problem
and all of that makes me wonder even
more why is pringles
dodging our question here we're truly
not asking
for a lot we've seen a ton of excellent
excellent pringles bods
we just need to know which one is canon
is it hermit pring
is it this hot daddy pring i'd prefer if
it was the second one i just need to
know the truth
because i know so many other pointless
facts about pringles i know that their
mascot's official name is
julius pringles and i know that the guy
who came up with the pringles tube
was so proud of his design that when he
died he had his ashes
put in a pringles can and buried which
is
a choice i also know that pringles calls
its product a crisp
for a reason and that is that they don't
meet the fda's definition
of a potato chip which is pretty wild
how
janky does your product need to be not
to meet
that basic definition my point here is
i know so much useless information about
pringles
but not the one thing that i really want
to know which is what is
julius pringles working with from the
neck down
do i need to know this no i don't do i
want to
yes very badly so much so that i'm
willing to give
ten thousand dollars to feeding america
if pringles answers my question
on the condition of course that they
don't spend a penny of that
money on pringles
because it's a garbage snack it's
garbage
the ball is in your court guys the
choice is yours do the right pring here
thank you so much for watching we'll be
back in february until then please
stay safe goodbye